ok super bowl est-ce que ce que vous
aimez la musique à ce que vous aimez la
musique mais ce que sinon vous
connaissez la musique classique
ouais ça fait
mais monsieur sait même pas quand c'est
comme ça que les cds compositeur de
musique classique mozart mozart c'est
bien là le plan femme a dit beethoven
il a fait le truc là quand tu entends
tan tan tan sang
[Musique]
céline dion céline dion compositeur de
musique classique
attendez messieurs s'il vous plaît par
les français de france ont dû pas un
compositeur hors que c'est une fille
aucune compositeur de musique classique
le compositeur alors pour marquer à bout
pour compositeur et ça devient pour
céline dion
vous sortez les papiers on oublie de
violon et au fait une dictée les
antennes partout dans les affaires ce
serait une perte terrible pour
l'orchestré et samir ne participait pas
au concert de fin d'année
il est fait pour la musique
pourtant quand les joue à la maison on
ne sait pas où c'est normal il est en
train d'apprendre
c'est toujours négatif avec le jeu je
pense que s'ils se mettaient au travail
sérieusement devra obtenir de très bons
résultats
j'ai dit à son professeur il perdait son
temps de vie qui ferait lanclas tu veux
reprendre le violon moi je sais pas moi
ouais
je peux faire autre chose jours
vous pouvez nous ont quelque chose et
c'est là maintenant
si vous voulez
il
[Musique]
il y
denis
[Musique]
et
m
nous
les
[Applaudissements]
oui
il
[Musique]
grasset
nokia pour toi c'est magnifique
hier
c'est new way
ici tous les matins du merlotte résidant
à deauville et sherazade c'est pour ça
c'est d'amis vous parle on va répéter
sherazade leur nom ces moulages ici
cimade est la mère et simbad les masques
l'ouverture
mettez vos plats lé ga shérazade sipa
robot spammeur la revue même comment
schouppe a fait un pas tout à fait tort
[Musique]
à deux trois tués pendant ce temps
pareil je vous repose à 2,3
tu utilises passé de rechute et vous
êtes passés ensemble on recommence à
deux à temps
[Musique]
mais chez les autres
un peu des cachets pas depuis alors je
dis qu elle s est battue la touche et au
marché à 2 3
[Musique]
et
je sors tu t'assois simon doubt votre
professeur de violon bonjour est ce que
vous connaissez la musique classique
vole ma femme a dit beethoven il a fait
le truc là quand encore
[Musique]
avant tout je veux m'assurer que vous
resterait bien que les enfants jusqu'au
concert puisqu'on va tu as parlé de
changer de parfum
allez on se remet en place venir un peu
plus pacifique s'il vous plaît ne sera
capable de se concentrer pendant 30
secondes
s'il vous plaît si l'on prend lui la
prendre par les français qu'est ce que
tu fais là le violon c'est pourquoi
c'est intéressant
oui ça vous des reçus par un élève de
plus s'il est motivé oui pourquoi pas
oui j'ai une proposition pour partir en
tournée pendant trois mois quand tu t'es
engagé à les emmener à la philharmonie
tu te souviens
j'ai pas pris ma décision
[Musique]
les druides a maintenant il est fait
pour la musique
toi tu vas trop sur la touche
faut tout donner et rendre vos parents
fiers de vous
[Musique]
ça s'est bien passé ton concert
en ce moment je travaille avec des
gamins
je suis bon j'aurai
je sais que vous arrêterez pas bhl je
compte sur vous d'accord
[Musique]